the business owner or the content
creator that has done the hard work of
writing and Publishing a book will
always have an advantage over the person
who has not people want to have authors
on their podcast people want to have
authors on their stages speaking even if
you know a lot about your subject you'll
learn even more by taking the leap and
deciding I'm going to write a book point
of writing a book is not direct income
from the book but it's the exposure
leads clients customers YouTube Secrets
has actually generated millions of
dollars
welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and in this episode
we're really going to be talking about
why every YouTube Creator should write a
book and I'm going to be covering why it
will make you a better content creator
how you can create additional income
streams from a book in multiple ways one
of the best ways to strengthen your
personal brand and lessons I've learned
having written multiple books as of
today I've technically written four
books and I'm going to be revealing a
story about some of those lessons and
this is going to be a two-part Series so
definitely subscribe and stick around
for all of the think media podcast
episodes because I believe this will be
valuable for you but if you have not
seen my best-selling book I co-wrote it
with my friend Benji Travis it's called
YouTube secrets and we just did the
second edition of the book and it's out
on physical ebook as well as audiobook
but here are the stats so you can kind
of know from what Authority and
credibility I'm coming from when I talk
about out writing a book and so YouTube
Secrets both editions have sold over a
hundred and five thousand copies the
book has received over
3122 reviews and it is directly
generated over 350 000 dollars so I'll
break more of that down as we go
throughout these two-part series
um and that's directly there's indirect
Revenue as well and I think that that is
one of the big opportunities for you as
you consider should you or should you
not write a book but one of the things
that I also have to disclose is that
this is actually my fourth book
um the first one would have been a book
called get notice embarrassing I had to
delete it but it was an e-book and it
really was just it was kind of a rushed
effort I think it added value to some
people but it was like a what 40 page
ebook or something like that that I
posted on Amazon the key though was I
learned some things and it helped my
next one be a little bit better now my
second book and this is a valuable
lesson was called YouTube for churches
the only format that I released that
book in was ebook but it was a very
powerful resource and I just designed
the cover on Photoshop at the time time
I wrote it all out in Microsoft Word I
had a lady that was a part of our church
named Rachel helped me edit the book I
use this software called ePub star and I
launched it on Amazon but it had so many
of the benefits we're going to talk
about and it was relatively easy to
produce what's cool is these days it's
even easier to self-publish a book but
that was very helpful for building my
credibility opening doors it led to
speaking engagements Consulting
engagements at the time I was a director
of communications at a church and it
really gave me a whole other platform to
launch off of in terms of my expertise
and so we're going to get into over
these two episodes
10 different reasons
um 12 different reasons of why I think
every YouTube Creator should write a
book and really every business owner and
entrepreneur
but after writing YouTube for churches
eventually Benji and I got together and
we self-published the first edition of
YouTube secrets that would be the most
professional step into the book writing
process and by far the biggest impact
and then just within the last kind of
like year and a half YouTube secret
second edition came out which was
heavily overhauled from the first
version but was not really an entirely
new book although it was a new ISBN
number I believe in some other things so
all that to say is I've done this a few
times there are others and I'll
introduce you to one because today's
podcast is actually brought to you by
startyourbook.live I'm co-hosting a free
training with my friend Chandler Bolt
from self-publishing school he's really
the go-to expert and should you want to
kind of lean into this or learn more
about this I highly recommend checking
out the show notes and registering for
that free class
but uh personally I have learned a lot
of lessons and discovered the benefits
of writing a book
um why you should consider writing a
book and specifically as a YouTube
Creator and so let's dive into these
tips and lessons number one it helps you
organize your thoughts better one of the
reasons why I think every YouTube
Creator should write a book is you are
essentially a thought leader you're a
knowledge worker and your job is to
communicate ideas
one of the challenges of course with
communication is Clarity is organization
is refining your ideas is speaking
powerfully and communicating powerfully
and so these simple practice
or a decision to write a book
could be one of the most beneficial
decisions you ever make if this was the
only point that benefited you when it
comes to writing a book
because if it's you versus a competitor
that are communicating the same thing on
YouTube in your business and your ideas
are more clear they're more refined
they're stronger
than you're going to have an advantage
and the simple process of committing to
writing a book
forces Clarity of your ideas
helps you refine your tips advice and
knowledge
and will help you gain greater clarity
about your topic number two writing a
book helps you learn and grow so I've
learned that writing a book all the way
back even in my first book called get
noticed and really in in full
transparency what ended up happening was
my friend Phil cook
was doing a con a compilation book which
is kind of a cool strategy where he got
friends of his Experts of similar
thought leadership and because he was
actually a consultant at the church we
were working at and I was the director
of communications and he had me I think
right about social media because for the
church at the time I was doing social
media Facebook ads Twitter personal
brand for the pastor the church social
media not just YouTube
so I had a chapter which was like a long
chapter like 30 pages 35 pages and I
thought why not turn that content that I
had already written for him
that was just no money exchange or
anything it was just
for a chance to kind of be featured and
be published
and therefore I was just sitting on this
content so I was like hey why don't I
upload a cover upload that onto Amazon
Kindle and why not and I sold it for
like 99 Cents and it just it was good it
just wasn't more than like a chapter
turned into a 99 cent ebook and so it
got some positive reviews and some not
so positive reviews but here's my point
is even on that very first book I ever
did it forced me to learn and grow and
it was like a nice first step towards
then writing YouTube for churches which
was a full and complete book maybe
around 100 pages and and then fast
forward to today YouTube secrets
is the best-selling YouTube strategy
book of all time there's reasons for
that one is getting coaching and help
and getting listening to experts and not
trying to do it on your own
but also because I had done it a couple
times before this is why in every area I
always want to encourage you
like start Messi start before you're
ready you might have heard that I've got
three four Failed YouTube channels
before my successful one but failures
are just the Stepping Stones to success
the commitment to just doing it
doing a version of it doing another one
and then doing another one
you could very well be a best-selling
New York Times author
but maybe not in your first book the
willingness to just start messy in every
area including this one could be the key
and what I've learned is that
99 of people
will not embrace
the pain
and the challenge and the difficulty and
the discipline honestly that it takes to
embrace writing a book now as you stick
throughout this two-part series there's
ways that may make it so much easier
but nevertheless it's still going to
take some effort right and so it forces
you to level up
it's a good personal development
exercise it'll help you be able to
explain your subject better what will
happen in embracing the process even
little nuances force you to research a
little bit more deeply or as you're
writing and you hit a block you'll be
like oh shoot and you have to go look
stuff up research it more maybe you
order some other books across reference
and so kind of number one and number two
if this was all it did for you
you again will be a better content
creator a better thought leader a better
leader a better subject matter expert
even if you know a lot about your
subject you'll learn even more by taking
the leap and deciding I'm going to write
a book
now the an objection might be well Sean
you know what relevance do books have in
today's world and we're going to hit
those as we go through more points but
again simply the commitment of writing
the book
will influence what you do elsewhere and
I would argue these first two points are
enough but let's go to number three
number three it's a great way to earn
money now some people would argue that
writing a book is not a very good way to
write money especially if you go
traditional publishing I recommend for
the majority of people listening to this
episode of the think media podcast I
would go self-publishing
chances are because maybe
you don't even have Publishers knocking
on your door but also because of the
hassle the length of time it takes do
they even care like different things and
there's so many pros and cons it's a
conversation to another time but the
cool thing about self-publishing
is arguably it's the more lucrative path
when you go traditional you get the
prestige and you maybe get some
distribution but a lot of times you'll
make a dollar 25 per book you'll make
less than a dollar per book whereas in
self-publishing
just uploading it to Amazon using
Amazon's tools
got a physical book you're making seven
eight nine dollars per Book on an ebook
you're at five bucks You're Gonna Keep
three you can make all this money on
audiobooks and so even if you only sell
a few copies
you can make actual legitimate money
self-publishing from the book itself
what most people would argue though is
that the point of writing a book is not
direct income from the book but it's the
exposure leads clients customers
speaking opportunities in the doors that
it opens
so let's break this down though number
three is writing a book is a great way
to earn money and you can earn from the
physical book and the ebook
we've earned and collected now about
three hundred thousand dollars from
YouTube Secrets it is just on Amazon
distributed through Amazon through all
their self-publishing tools that's the
physical book in the ebook the audiobook
has generated another fifty thousand
deeper than that though what about
clients leads people that know like and
Trust You discovery of the YouTube
channel all of the above YouTube Secrets
has actually generated millions of
dollars if you think about clients leads
and there's some direct tracking but I
think the other way to think about it is
brand lift
and what brand lift means is just the
authority awareness that comes from
writing a book and when people when the
perception of your brand is strengthened
and when more leads clients and
awareness comes in if you have products
and services which we do at think media
then that leads to
more money being earned in fact what
that free class that Chandler and I are
co-hosting is about is how to write and
publish a book and how to add six
figures in Revenue to your business this
year by publishing a book a huge key
there right is that
that six figures over a hundred thousand
dollars for the majority is not going to
come from Book Sales some money can come
in that way but it's what is that
leading to what else is that leading to
number four writing a book opens up more
chances for Success increased
opportunity speaking podcasts
one of the things as someone that likes
to have guests on the very think media
podcast is I love having authors on
because I know a couple things they have
done the hard work of getting clarifying
their ideas
right they have learned and grown in the
process they are deeper subject matter
matter experts it's not to say that
someone can't be a deep subject matter
expert if they haven't written a book
but there's such an acceleration of
trust in my mind if they have a book I'm
like okay awesome not only that it helps
me as a podcast interviewer
because oftentimes I I'm basically 100
of the time they either send me the book
or I purchase it and then I tab through
it and I can find some of their
Frameworks and their ideas which helps
me conduct an interview and make it
valuable for you here listening to the
think media podcast so people want to
have authors on their podcast people
want to have authors on their stages
speaking virtual events or actual
in-person events and then media
so getting discovered
YouTube Secrets was has been listed in
many Publications now in various ways
but I think Vice Rest in Peace by the
way didn't they just go bankrupt
um somebody I'm sure will acquire them
uh Forbes entrepreneur a few different
places so you could get featured in
media and writing a book is helpful for
that which lists your brand but also did
you know that Amazon is a search engine
so even writing a good book you can rank
for something specific on Amazon it's
his own search engine and get discovered
on Amazon versus just getting discovered
on social or just getting discovered on
YouTube or just getting discovered on
podcasts so it just kicks open
more chances for success and then number
five writing a book makes your personal
brand stronger and so a business owner
with a published book has an advantage
a content creator with a published book
has an advantage over a business owner
or a content creator that does not
and so the reason I really believe now
especially
for the majority I would argue the think
media podcast community that is teaching
something education entrepreneur
business owner again if you're if you're
heavy entertainment this might not be
relevant although it's fascinating to
see how many kind of quote unquote
YouTubers over the years have written a
book that are more entertainment it's
it's sometimes more of a humorous angle
or a memoir angle and all of those
things are relevant as well
one of the things on the class that I'm
doing with Chandler he helps people do
fiction and Memoirs and Legacy books and
different things like that but where
this is really aligned is if you have a
product
service someday you plan on creating one
you're teaching something you're
educating
the alignment is so strong
and there's maybe a lot of people
that are your competitors so imagine
one that when someone's comparing
options and they see okay you're a
publish author you got a book on Amazon
it's got a few positive reviews they can
see that you've organized your ideas
they can see that right you can mail
that to them
they called books as the new business
cards and the Better Business Cards so
you send them a book in the mail and
they go oh my gosh and then they want to
hire you work with you it just becomes
this way to build your personal brand
and the business owner or the content
creator that has done the hard work of
writing and Publishing a book will
always have an advantage over the person
who has not and so are you thinking
about writing a book do you have any
more questions I want to encourage you
part two is coming out with the second
seven reasons we covered five and a
little bit of the backstory in this
episode so definitely subscribe if
you're not subscribed and if you're
interested in checking out the free
class on how to write and publish a book
that will add six figures and revenue to
your business this year go to
startyourbook.liveknot.com
dot l-i-v-e dot Live start your
book.live or hit the link in the
description description Chandler is
going to be breaking down how to use a
book to double your lead sales and
referrals how to guarantee the book is
set up to actually make money from day
one how to write your book in a weekend
without writing a single word pretty
powerful and this is why what's so cool
I like I wish I knew a lot of these
strategies back when I was writing get
noticed and that's why I'm so grateful
that I've discovered self-publishing
school since then because a lot of times
people make it too hard they get lost in
the details or they start but they don't
finish the book's just on your hard
drive it's just on Google Docs it's in
word and so I think if this is it is all
interesting to you then definitely check
out startyourbook.live how to
successfully launch your book and create
a six-figure book funnel really cool
class and you know it's not for
everybody because this might not
resonate with you but if you're thinking
about it then definitely check all of
that out and rate and review the podcast
if you are grateful for the think media
podcast my name is Sean Cannell rhymes
with YouTube channel and I look forward
to seeing you in the next episode